i got hit in the helmet which knocked me
out believe it or not it knocked me out
for about 20 seconds
basically these have got layers of
kevlar in and it's designed to go around
so if you shot me there it will come out
the back
this is a smitten spender's uh scope
it's german made
um i think the best scopes it's nice
clear glass when i say clear glass when
you look through it
it's like looking through your eyeballs
you know here i've got spirit level
to make sure when i'm shooting i'm not
on a cant
now a can is when the rifle is on the
tilt if the rifle's on the tilt the
bullet's not going to travel straight
it doesn't the bullet doesn't travel
straight anyway it curves
because inside the barrel you've got
rifling and that rifling
goes right all right this is where it
gets complicated
so it goes right and then you have the
karaos effect of the world
taking effect from the center i think
the world moves
a thousand and fifty miles an hour and
as it goes higher and
lower to the north and south pole slower
it gets
so where you are in the world you have
to judge
the carriers effect of the world will
take effect of that bullet as well
so if the world's going right your
bullets going right
you're gonna have to put more left on
your reflection and that's how it works
and if you're and if you've got a canton
as well
the bullet's not gonna go straight so
much into it
you know it's not all about just lying
down and shooting
this is a mark 6 alpha helmet now when i
did my last tour all these new helmets
came out but my head is so
vast they never had one to fit my head
so i had to stick with
the old-fashioned one basically i was on
a mission
and we had to um secure a left flank
and i didn't i thought to myself
when the mission was set up i haven't
checked over there
so i i went over there in my vehicle and
um there were two taliban there um
arming up
and they rinsed me they rinsed me um
i got hit in the helmet which knocked me
out believe it or not it knocked me out
for about 20 seconds
basically these have got layers of
kavalar in and it's designed to go
around
so if you shot me there it will come out
the back
my other two vehicles came up to support
me
and and i realized that i got shot in my
man bag we call them man bags
because you put your magazines in and
i've got shot through there
um and obviously on the vehicle itself
you have a gympie machine gun with an
ammo box
that got shot so i couldn't return fire
because everything was crushed and um
to this day now i cannot remember
anything to this day now because i got
knocked out
and then my driver remembers everything
and he told me that i looked at him
and he was in the footwell of his
vehicle
and i stood up i took the box off i
reloaded the box
we were still getting fire in there and
i stayed on top of that hill
i stayed on top of that hill and
extracted
all my blokes off the top of the hill
all the vehicles they all went down to
dead ground
and my driver said you weren't moving
and i wasn't moving without an order
and i can't remember anything i had
really bad concussion from it
um because of the distance he got shot
and i spent the night in the field
ambulance
but i refused to go back
to bastion because i wanted to stay on
my blokes i felt i needed to stay in my
blokes
so in the morning i said i felt fine
which i didn't and um i went back and
joined my lads and we carried on the
mission
and you see some lads that don't wear
their helmet and i always
i always brought that in and i said you
need to wear your helmet
because it can save your life an inch
lower
and i won't be here now an inch lower i
won't be here
i looked up and i could see two guys
with a
pkm belt fed
russian machine gun and they were
hammering down
on the lads my rifle only shoots 1500
meters
so i had to i call it lobbing
i lobbed the bullet in